Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the
differences between Denny's
in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
This is an All-American Slam
breakfast at a UK Denny's.
It consists of two
scrambled eggs with cheddar,
two sausages, two pieces of bacon,
some American-style hash brown,
and two triangles of toast.
This bacon looks a little sad.
I know you guys like
crispy bacon in the US.
An All-American Slam breakfast in the US
comes with the following by default.
Three scrambled eggs with
cheese, two bacon strips,
two sausage links, hash
browns, and a choice
of either four triangles
of toast or two pancakes.
We went with pancakes.
The largest breakfast in the UK is this,
the Grand Slam Slugger.
It's the same as the All-American Slam,
but instead of the toast,
you get two pancakes.
Now, when I saw this on the menu,
I didn't think changing
the toast for pancakes
would actually add that much size to it,
but these things are huge.
I think two of these plus the rest,
and that is a substantial breakfast.
Our largest slam is the Lumberjack Slam.
It comes with two pancakes,
two or three eggs, I can't tell,
grilled ham, you have a
choice of two sausages links
and two bacon strips or four of either,
so I went with four bacon strips,
hash browns, and four triangles of toast.
Look at this.
Now here is a guy who's ready
for a full day of lumberjacking.
You can get some of Denny's
iconic sandwiches in the UK,
including the Grand Slamwich.
We're going to weigh a Grand Slamwich
in both countries to see whose is bigger.
Now, we all know the Moons
Over My Hammy in plate version.
I didn't know this,
but apparently now it's
in sandwich version.
Here it is.
You got the eggs, you got the ham, right?
This is a UK Moons Over My Hammy.
I don't get that pun.
I'm really sorry, guys.
No diner would be complete
without American-style
pancakes in the United States.
An order of pancakes comes
by default as a two-piece.
One, two. One, two.
An order of pancakes in the
UK also means two pancakes.
However, when I went to
order them on the website,
it also gave me the option to add
a single additional
extra pancake for £1.99,
and it let me do that up to 99 times.
So if you do really, really love pancakes,
you can order 101
pancakes from a UK Denny's
for a small, small price of £203.80.
But how big are the pancakes themselves?
We're going to measure them to find out.
So, our pancake, I'm going
to say 16 centimeters across.
And our pancake weighs around 147 grams.
6 inches?
I once caught a pancake this big.
Yeah, again, the Tinder profile, like.
The weight of the same pancake.
This specific 6-inch pancake
at Denny's weighs
148 grams.
Here are all the items
you'll find at a UK Denny's
that you won't find in the US.
And here's everything you'll find
at a US Denny's you
will not find in the UK.
Let's start with the breakfast items.
Our largest slam breakfast,
the Grand Slam Slugger,
is in fact an exclusive.
We have a couple exclusive
slam breakfasts in the US.
The before-mentioned Lumberjack.
I mean, I'm curious about
this fried ham steak.
If you want to eat something at Denny's
that doesn't go straight
for your arteries,
you can get the Fit Slam.
It is two English muffins,
I see spinach, egg whites, tomatoes,
looks like feta cheese. Let's get in here.
I bet that's great when it's hot,
but it is not hot and
therefore it is not great.
Next up we have the veggie breakfast.
In here, we have what
seems to be an omelet
made with peppers, some spinach,
and maybe some onion as well.
There are these little
cubes, almost cubes,
little square things of potato.
And then just a couple of bits of
either boiled or steamed broccoli.
And if you're not eating
eggs, we have a vegan version.
It looks like all they've really done is
just replace the eggs with more potato.
Benny, which is of course
short for eggs Benedict.
Everything needs a fun name in America.
With a poached egg,
ham, hollandaise sauce,
not to be confused with holiday sauce.
That's pretty good.
Of course, we also have a Southwest Benny.
Southwest?
Oh, wait, no, this is, like,
it has, like, chorizo and stuff.
That actually kind of rules.
I'm surprised. That's
actually pretty good.
Something that may mystify the UK viewers,
as you will see various
versions throughout this video
of what I'm about to show
you, biscuits and gravy,
chicken biscuits and gravy.
It's going to be some sort of combination
of fried chicken, or some cases steak,
smothered in the white gravy we have,
a gravy that is filled with sausage
and also on our biscuits.
Deep-fried chicken covered
in our white sauce.
It's a gravy that's sausage-flavored.
Cheese. Not a scone.
Damn it, it's really good.
Next to that is a Santa Fe bowl.
Again, does Santa Fe just
mean, like, salsa and chorizo?
Get these type of potatoes,
these sliced-up seasoned ones.
Also mushrooms and veggies.
Another fried gravy thing.
This is a country-fried steak.
Yes, a steak that has been fried
and put our white gravy on it!
And it also comes with eggs.
Kind of like a big McNugget
that's kind of more beef-flavored.
And speaking of steaks, you can
get a T-bone steak and eggs.
Denny's, what's with the
onions and mushrooms, guys?
I want a steak. Like ...
I assure you there is a
steak underneath this.
Yeah, there it is. There it is. T-bone.
Doorstop of a steak.
Look at the size of this thing.
I mean, this is ...
Man, they destroyed this piece of meat.
This thing is, like,
the most well-done thing
I've ever bit into.
It's like biting into a wallet.
Skip the steak at Denny's.
We have a few omelet options in the UK,
but only one of them is exclusive.
It's the ham and cheese omelet.
I'm surprised you guys
don't have these in America
because I'd say ham and cheese is probably
the most commonly eaten omelet in the UK.
So, we have exclusive omelets of our own,
and they are way more elaborate
than the UK's simple ham and cheese.
Here we have the Mile High Denver omelet,
the Ultimate omelet, and the
Philly cheesesteak omelet.
Now, you watching right now are thinking,
"Hey, Joe, which is which?"
I have no idea.
So another game we're going to play
in this episode is Omelet Roulette.
♪ What's in the omelet? ♪
So I'm going to take a bite of each one
and see if I can guess which omelet it is.
All right.
Denver.
Ham, peppers, onions, cheese.
The next omelet.
I'm seeing sausage.
The question is, does the
viewer want it to be tilted?
I think, if we could put
a poll on the screen.
Should he tilt it?
I think a lot of people
would be like, please don't.
Yeah, this is the Ultimate one.
Sausage, obviously.
Bacon, peppers, onions,
mushrooms, tomato, cheese.
Eh, not bad.
Everything's so wet.
It's dripping with water.
And this one must be therefore
the Philly cheesesteak.
Grilled prime rib, peppers,
onions, mushroom, Swiss cheese.
Ooh, prime.
You will not find the following
pancake options in the UK.
Starting down here,
they got the choconana, which
is chocolate and banana.
Every one of these comes
with, like, eggs and,
again, you just don't get pancakes.
I feel like I want to point this out.
Are you aware, UK? Because I
haven't seen Harry's footage.
Every pancake order comes
with eggs and hash browns and meats.
Look at this. It's
ridiculous. It's so much food.
Next to that is the double berry.
I mean, I see strawberries.
Oh. Because it's a berry pancake.
Ugh. Actually, it's not very good.
The strawberries are weird.
Hearty nine-grain pancakes.
I can't tell how many
grains are in this pancake.
Can you at home?
I have no idea.
And the cinnamon roll pancakes.
I'm sure at this point the
Cinnabon episode is out.
Oh, my God.
Ooh, that's trouble.
That's really good.
And at the end, this is really funny.
It's a crepe. A berry vanilla crepe.
There's something weird
with their strawberries.
We have some exclusive
pancake options of our own.
One thing to point out is that Americans
have this kind of
pancakes-for-breakfast culture,
and that really does not exist in the UK.
Over here, pancake generally means crepe,
so like a thin pancake,
and they're traditionally
more eaten for dessert.
Denny's pancakes in the UK
are the kind of thick American-style ones.
However, the toppings and the sauces
tend to reflect our
dessert-pancake culture a bit more.
We'll start with a
classic pancake topping,
which is Nutella.
I pronounce it "nut-ell-uh."
Some people say "new-tell-uh."
Leon: Who says "new-tell-uh"?
I've definitely — do
Americans say "new-tell-uh"?
Do you guys say "new-tell-uh"?
That's horrible. Please don't do that.
It's "nut-ell-uh."
Over here we have the
double chocolate pancakes.
I think the double chocolate refers to
the chocolate chips in
the pancakes themselves
and also this rather large amount
of chocolate drizzle on top.
Next up, we have some
strawberry dream pancakes,
which have not held up
super well in transit,
I'll be honest.
These are looking less like
strawberry dream pancakes
and more like strawberry
nightmare pancakes.
What is this sauce that's just, like,
fallen off the pancake?
Like, a very sweet
maybe white-chocolate-vanillary-type
cream thing.
Over here, we have the
Oreo cookie pancakes.
I think there are chocolate pieces
or maybe the cookie pieces
in the pancake as well.
Then it's topped with some more
of this kind of sweet
cream stuff they have.
Next up, we have a Kinder Bueno pancake.
Do Americans know what Kinder Bueno is?
It's a chocolate bar.
Very popular in Europe and the UK.
I don't know what the cream
stuff inside of it is,
but one of the best-tasting
things in the world.
And then, finally, because
it's near Valentine's Day
here in the UK while we're filming this,
we can get some Valentine's pancakes.
These red velvet ones.
These are the exact colors that you see
on snakes that you are
supposed to run away from
if you see them in the wild.
We don't have any crepes
on the menu in the UK,
but we do have waffles.
These are also generally
desserts in the UK,
and Denny's serves them
in the following flavors.
Here we have a fresh fruit waffle.
Each one seems to be one
whole circular waffle
cut into quarters and then topped
with powdered sugar and
some other toppings.
With the fresh fruit one you're getting
some banana and some strawberry.
Here we have a golden waffle.
That's a waffle with golden syrup,
which is kind of like a
British version of maple syrup.
Some of the waffles on the menu
also come as Liège-style waffles.
Liège is a place in
Belgium. Belgian waffles.
They're a little bit more dense
than the American waffles.
Next up, we have a Nutella
waffle, not "new-tell-uh."
Then we have a Kinder Bueno waffle.
The sauce stuff really does capture
the flavor of Kinder Bueno.
You can just get a plain waffle
with just some of the whipped butter
that you get with the pancakes.
And then finally, another Liège option
is the banana and salted caramel waffle.
Great flavor combination.
Big fan of that.
Now that we've reset
the table, let's move on
to some other options,
starting with sandwiches.
Start here with the New York melt.
We're more American than the Americans.
Let's try the pastrami.
We're not very good at deli
meats in the UK on average.
Up next, we have the three-cheese melt.
Pretty much just a grilled cheese
with three types of cheese in here.
Here we have the Mac and Me.
This is a grilled-cheese sandwich
filled with mac and cheese and bacon bits.
We've just been discussing
double carbs and established
that there are circumstances
where double carb is OK,
but the bread-pasta combination
in this circumstance
seems to just unsettle me
for some reason I can't
really put a word to.
Then our last exclusive
sandwich is the club sandwich.
You guys do have a club
sandwich in the US,
but I believe it has avocado,
whereas ours does not.
We have a bunch of exclusive
sandwich options in the US.
I mean, the website splits them into
classic breakfast options and
meats and handheld options.
All right, we'll start
with the breakfast one,
the My Hammy Spice.
It's the same thing except
it's got jalapeños in it.
Look at that.
This thing is just dripping with butter.
And then we have the rest,
which I don't think are
supposed to be eaten for breakfast.
They do have a Brisk-B-Q
melt and a Brisk-It-All melt,
which I was not able to get today,
but what we do have is
the Cali club sandwich.
We also got the Super Bird.
What? What is this? Like ...
Turkey, bacon, and tomato and cheese.
Not bad.
The Big Dipper melt.
This is just a, what
looks to be a patty melt
with about half a gallon of au jus.
Look at that.
I love a good patty melt.
That's a pretty good one.
Next up is this monstrosity,
the fried cheese melt.
Now, when I heard that
and put in for the order,
I was assuming it was
going to be like, in a way,
something like grilled
cheese, like they fried cheese
or it's just a funny way
of saying grilled cheese.
No, not at all.
This is actually a
sandwich that consists of
mozzarella sticks.
Look at this. Are you
kidding me? Look at this.
I'm going to take the
top off of one of these.
Look at this.
And it even comes with
marinara sauce, yeah.
It even says in the
script that Harry wrote,
"Mozzarella stick sandwich.
You've got to be kidding me."
We are not kidding you, apparently.
We have one.
That's the stupidest
thing I've ever eaten.
Other sandwiches you can
get that I did not get
include the Nashville hot chicken melt,
the BLT,
and the crispy chicken
bacon ranch sandwich.
In one of the boxes when we
were unpacking everything,
I just found three chicken tenders.
I was a bit confused
because we didn't order
any chicken tenders. I ate
them because I was hungry.
And now looking back I
realize that that was part of
one of our main options,
which is chicken and waffles.
You get a portion of plain waffles
and three chicken tenders
and some maple syrup.
Combine them all, chicken and waffles.
But unfortunately,
already gone. Sorry, guys.
Moving on. We have the
barbecue bacon burger.
It's a single cheeseburger with
two large rashers of bacon.
For the vegetarians, UK Denny's
also has a veggie burger.
Veggie burgers just always
look a bit sad, don't they?
Also, where's the sauce, guys?
Come on. This is dry as a bone.
It smells almost like falafel,
or maybe like a vegetable samosa.
And our last sandwich
option is a chicken burger.
General note here, Denny's,
please sauce your burgers.
These are all quite dry.
But here we have two chicken tenders
with a slice of cheddar cheese in a bun.
This looks like a spaceship.
Is there a "Star Wars" spaceship
that's shaped like this?
That's shaped really, like,
I don't know. I don't know what it is.
Then for the health-conscious among us,
we have two salad options,
starting with the crispy chicken salad.
And a grilled chicken salad.
In the US, we also have a ton
of main-course options
you won't find in the UK.
Didn't get all of them.
I will start with the burgers.
In the US, we have bacon avocado burger.
There's also the before-shown Slamburger.
That's all the Grand Slam
breakfast in burger form.
So weird, yet it exists.
It's got a little egg hanging on here.
Ah!
And the flamin' five-pepper burger.
There's also a bourbon bacon burger
that was not available
at the time of filming.
We also have bowls, bowls, bowls.
So many bowls to choose from.
I only got one.
That's the Mama D's pot roast.
I'm assuming the D stands for Denny's,
or delicious, or deadly.
There's also the crazy spicy bowl
and the bourbon chicken bowl.
Entrées, you saw a lot of
this in the breakfast section,
so I don't have to waste
too much time on it.
First thing we got here is the
Plate Lickin' fried chicken,
and this one I got a
side of mashed potatoes
and a little veggie medley.
The next thing we got
here is the sirloin steak.
Who told you to smother this in
onions and mushrooms?
This is a hockey puck.
Other sides you can get:
fries and a veggie medley.
T-bone steak, you've seen
it, with corn and vegetables.
This right here,
country-fried steak dinner.
Two country-fried steaks
smothered in white sausage gravy,
and, of course, comes with corn,
and I think that's mashed potatoes.
And you can also get
a wild Alaskan salmon.
I'm not bringing cooked
fish in the studio.
Not happening. All right?
Use your imagination.
And you can also get a Cobb salad.
Didn't get that either
because it's a salad.
What about the exclusive
starters and sides?
Well, in the UK it's kind
of like a beige buffet.
Here we have chicken poppers,
just bite-size pieces of fried chicken.
This food is so dry I'm having to
skip ahead to the exclusives,
which thankfully for me
includes beer.
Three of our UK exclusive sides
are actually forms of fries.
Here we have cheesy fries.
Chips and cheese is a
classic British dish,
so I'm glad that they have
localized their menu to the UK.
Then, in addition to the cheesy fries,
you can add bacon to
create cheesy bacon fries.
And on top of that,
you can add jalapeños
to create loaded fries.
This is like a Pokémon
evolving in its three stages.
Cheese fries evolves
into bacon cheesy fries,
evolves into loaded fries.
The Charizard of fries.
Then our last side dish
is a British classic.
It's everyone's favorite, baked beans.
There they are.
These do smell like British baked beans,
so kind of tomato-based
rather than barbecue.
I don't have a spoon.
Should I just sip from this
like a little shot glass?
Leon: They're beans.
They're beans.
Leon: What's that meant
to go with on this menu?
What wouldn't this go with
on the menu, is my question.
Leon: Waffles, probably.
Beans and waffles?
I reckon a bean pancake could work.
You tempted fate here.
Leon: What you're doing is sick.
Charlie: Ugh, God.
[Leon and Charlie laughing]
No, that's bad.
I can't even pretend that was good.
Denny's has boneless wings.
This is what they look like.
I don't know what sauces
they have for dipping.
Nobody asked.
Other exclusive sides
you can get in the US,
you saw all the ones from earlier.
These are ones that you've
probably seen before.
Biscuits and gravy, scones and gravy,
an English muffin, ironically
not in England. That's weird.
We also have right here
this whole-grain rice.
Other sides that we have
either mixed within dishes
you've seen or not seen at all,
wavy-cut french fries,
seasoned cut french fries,
red rustic mashed potatoes.
I saw those somewhere.
The fresh vegetable medley
and the soup of the day,
which is, from what I
remember, beef vegetable,
and they told us couldn't
get it till after 11,
and we picked up the food at 10:45.
Now we're on to the desserts,
starting at the back here
with chocolate fudge cake
with what at one point was whipped cream.
Then we have a few cheesecake options,
starting with a Reese's cheesecake.
Doesn't look very appealing.
They've just kind of dumped
what I assume is this kind of
peanut-buttery, caramel-y
stuff on top of it.
That's not bad.
Moving on from Reese's, we
have an Oreo cheesecake,
so the same cheesecake but with
Oreo pieces crumbled on top.
And finally a Nutella cheesecake.
It has fallen on its side,
so, therefore, I can
prop it up, like a TV.
Then we have some French toast options.
I'm not sure why Denny's
classifies these as desserts,
but apparently chocolaty
pancakes are a breakfast food.
We'll start back here
with Oreo French toast.
French toast, not much of
a thing here in the UK.
What we have is eggy bread, which is like,
the similar start, where
you take the bread,
dunk it in egg, and fry it,
but then we'll have it as a savory dish
rather than as a breakfast/dessert.
Then we have a banoffee French toast.
For the uninitiated,
banoffee is banana and
toffee amalgamated together.
Then we have strawberry
dream French toast.
Fresh strawberries and
some vanillary icing.
Here's three exclusives
you can only get in the US
and not the UK. New York-style cheesecake.
Whoa! Hey, I'm walking here!
The lava cookie skillet.
I'm assuming that's this.
I can't break it.
And it comes with ice
cream, I'm sure for dipping.
Yeah, pretty good.
And the double chocolate pancake puppies.
Like hush puppies, but pancake.
Mm, eh.
Then we have a a couple
more dessert options
and some milkshakes.
Here, we have a strawberry
ice cream sundae
and a caramel ice cream sundae.
Ignore the straw.
I definitely did not
think it was a milkshake.
I think we have identified all the shakes.
I believe this is millionaire shortbread,
peanut butter shake,
a white chocolate and strawberry shake,
cookie shake, a vegan vanilla shake,
then this I think is
Bueno, and this is Nutella.
I think my favorite would probably be
the millionaire shortbread one.
Very sweet but very tasty.
And after all that, the
final exclusive, alcohol.
Thank God.
We can get a few beer
and other alcohol options here in the UK,
including this Coors Light.
I think there's a Peroni beer
and some Kopparberg fruity cider.
Cheers, guys.
According to Dennys.com,
a website I now have an account with,
the nearest Denny's to this
studio in Burbank, California,
an All-American Slam
will run you $15.29.
An All-American Slam from
a UK Denny's costs £10.99,
which at the time of
recording this was $13.23.
That makes the American version
15% more expensive than the UK's.
But there's better value
to be found elsewhere
on the US menu: a stack of pancakes.
These very pancakes. Wow, is this right?
Two of these cost $3.49.
Bro, that is cheap.
Two pancakes in the UK,
that'll cost you £5.79
which is around $6.97.
That means that the UK pancakes
are 99% more expensive.
I don't consider Denny's fast food.
I consider it more of a restaurant
chain, like TGI Fridays.
Even though Denny's does
really lean into breakfast,
it is 24 hours.
So Denny's for me was always a place
that you can go at any time.
Just pretty much anything
you would find in a diner,
you'll find at a Denny's.
I used to go there a lot in high school
because you could smoke in a Denny's,
and it's open 24 hours.
So we'd just drink
coffee, smoke cigarettes,
split an appetizer, and
drive our waitress crazy.
Harry wants to know,
what time of day are
you going to a Denny's?
I think it's more like
what time of your life
are you going to Denny's?
To me, I could be wrong,
but the only people I see at Denny's
are teenagers who want
to get out of the house
and hang out and they
can't get into a bar yet,
and retired people who want
to have a $4 breakfast.
So once you come into
this world on your own,
you start by going to
Denny's with your friends,
then you go off, you live a life,
you have a family, a career,
you make an impact in the world,
and once you retire,
back to the same Denny's.
Full circle.
I like the standalone diner from the '50s,
has some name like Bertha's
or Ethel's or Fred's,
and you have as much
coffee as you want, right?
And a patty melt, fries.
Yeah. That to me — the chain is like, no.
I like the standalone place.
For me, I have to say
this is quite expensive
for what it is.
We don't really have a
diner culture in the UK,
but what we do have is caffs.
Caffs, or short for café,
it's kind of like a
ubiquitous British thing.
You'll find a couple
of caffs in every town
where you can just get a
really cheap and cheerful meal
on the go, in a hurry,
and they'll really, really sort you out,
generally for a lot less money
than what this will run you.
Between caffs and greasy spoons,
which are similar but not quite the same,
we really have breakfast
culture covered in that regard.
That's where you're going
to get your full English,
your toast, your kind
of terrible cup of tea
but in quite a nice way.
Yeah, so I'm not sure Denny's would really
be bringing too much to the table.
When I say we don't really
have much of a diner culture
in the UK, I guess that's
evidenced by the fact
that chains like Denny's really
haven't taken off over here.
We had to actually travel to Wales,
to Swansea to get this one
because that's where our only
Denny's in the whole UK is.
I gotta say, it was kind of
popular when we were there.
It was pretty busy.
Lots of families taking
their kids out for some food.
I think maybe Denny's
currently is just more of a
gimmicky American-style thing in the UK.
If they did try to roll
out, I'm not sure that
it would be really kind of filling a void
that we have that isn't
already filled by caffs,
greasy spoons, or something else.
Unfortunately, Denny's in
the UK doesn't disclose
any of its nutritional information.
Denny's in the US does, however,
so let's take a look
at some menu classics.
One thing to note,
especially with the slams,
is that customizing your order
can drastically change the calories.
For example, take this All-American Slam.
If you choose turkey bacon as your meat,
hash brown as your potato,
and white toast as your bread,
it comes out to 1,050
calories. Respectable.
On the flip side, you can
get the All-American Slam
with sausage links, french
fries — french fries? Come on.
And then upgrade your toast to an order
of cinnamon roll pancakes,
that doubles the calories of the meal,
taking it to 2,300.
That's 115% of your
daily recommended intake.
And the main culprit here,
if it wasn't obvious, the
cinnamon roll pancakes.
Just two of these contain 1,100 calories.
A nutritional-information
document from Denny's
dated back in 2020
also suggested that two
cinnamon roll pancakes
with cream cheese icing
contains 157 grams of sugar.
That's 254% of your daily allowance.
Zoom in for effect.
Gah!
These things are huge.
I think two of these plus the rest,
and that is a substantial breakfast. Wow.
They're the size of my face.
And I've got a big face!